una lluviosa mañana de domingo adam se
despertó al oír a su mamá quejarse pues
la casa estaba sucia mamá siempre está
enojada cuando llueve comentó el hermano
de adán así que adam decidió verificar
si el comentario era realmente correcto
durante el siguiente año el registro
cada vez que llovía y cada vez que su
mamá estaba enojada lo que encontró fue
muy interesante días lluviosos y mamá
enojada eran eventos totalmente
independientes parte de sus datos se
muestran en la tabla de abajo rellena la
tabla de frecuencias con los valores que
faltan y la tabla tiene los días en que
estaba lloviendo los días que no estaba
lloviendo el total de días y en esos
días que estaba lloviendo cuando estaba
enojada cuando no estaba enojada la mamá
o cuando no estaba lloviendo también
cuando estaba enojada o cuando no estaba
enojada la mamá de todos los días del
año se tiene un total de 35 días que
estaba lloviendo 330 días que no estaba
lloviendo también encontró que durante
el año 73 días su mamá estaba enojada
mientras que 292 días su mamá no estaba
pero entonces como le vamos a hacer aquí
tenemos una tabla con cuatro celdas por
llenar aparentemente no tenemos
suficiente información pero lo que
tenemos que recordar es que nos están
diciendo que días lluviosos y mamá
enojada son eventos totalmente
independientes lo cual quiere decir que
la probabilidad déjame hacer esto con un
color que resalte esto es que los
eventos sean independientes quiere decir
que la probabilidad aquí mi pluma está
comportándose raro que la probabilidad
de mamá enojada la probabilidad de mamá
enojada dado que
está lloviendo la probabilidad de mamá
enojada dado que está lloviendo esto no
depende de que esté lloviendo es decir
es lo mismo que la probabilidad de mamá
enojada la probabilidad de mamá enojada
en general y esto que nos dice bueno
basándonos en nuestra tabla esta
probabilidad la podemos calcular cómo
sigue la probabilidad de que mamá esté
enojada así en general es 73 sobre 365
vamos a calcular esto esto es igual a 73
que son los días en que mamá esté
enojada entre el total de días que son
365 esta es los días en que mamá está
enojada de un total de 365 días es la
probabilidad que mamá esté enojada en
general y esto es igual a punto 2 esto
es igual a punto 2 o lo que es lo mismo
la prioridad de mamá enojada es igual
20% así que la probabilidad de que mamá
esté enojada dado que está lloviendo
debe de ser igual también al 20% así es
que dado que está lloviendo también el
20 por ciento de las veces mamá está
enojada esto es porque son eventos
independientes sin importar si está
lloviendo no mamá está 20 por ciento de
las veces enojada mamá va a estar
enojada 20 por ciento de las veces si
está lloviendo y 20 por ciento de las
veces si no está lloviendo esto es
consistente con lo que nos están
diciendo que los eventos son totalmente
independientes
así es que cuál es el 20% de 35 el 20%
es un quinto un quinto de 35 es 7 de
nueva cuenta lo único que hice fue
calcular el 20 por ciento 35 que 777 35
7 este es 28 y ahora 77 73 menos 7 es
igual
66 66 y 330 - bueno hay dos maneras de
hacerlo vamos a ser mejor 292 menos 28
esto va a ser veamos 292 menos 8 284
menos 20 264 y cuadran los números y 66
más 264 es igual a 330 la clave aquí fue
lo que encontró que fue muy interesante
que días lluviosos y mamá enojada eran
eventos totalmente independientes es
decir sin importar que estuviera
lloviendo o no estuviera lloviendo la
probabilidad de que mamá estuviera
enojada tenía que ser exactamente la
misma y pudimos obtener una estimación
de la probabilidad que mamá estuviera
enojada del 20 por ciento a partir del
total de días que tenemos en la tabla y
como a partir de los datos se encontró
que los eventos eran independientes la
manera en que llenamos esto fue a partir
de que la probalidad de que la mamá
estuviera enojada ya sea que estuviera
lloviendo o no estuviera lloviendo tenía
que ser exactamente la misma y así fue
como llenamos la tabla